yeah hello welcome to this video playing
Jerome so I don't quite the CDO for this
F for business no and a form can be kind
of tricky yeah this line I've had on the
board a couple of times and I never
really felt it's so dangerous they often
played Bishop takes up skating exactly
that I always felt that black is ok here
and right from the bed ok no got the
better porn structure as simple as it
sounds but it is it is the case mmm ok
maybe stop F for bit of an ambitious
move but i'm probably not bad of course
this is an incredibly solid position for
for for white very difficult yet to play
for something wit with the black
business ok to push this way and i'm an
f4 it's not hitting any time soon so the
night has to be reroute it anyway the
knight on c6 is not good so 93 and i'm
going to play it back the question is
where to the a bishop is six doesn't
strike me as being that great so maybe
here g-form
don't you for that h mart okay that's
not an issue again I don't think it
threatens much but ok I keep it i'm
putting this bag up the bishop also
doesn't have a particularly clear
function or h3 now that I've prevented
our form so ultimately some f 6 h 5 h
voice what i want to do I wonder about
95 but I think I can just take it I
don't think this is any anything special
for white d for him i would like to play
king e seven but then night at five is
really hitting me hard okay he might eat
he might just take i think i think i
want the bishop sorry I think I wanted
then that the rook should be able to
move okay so this one hmm I did not have
this on the radar which is pretty
embarrassing
yeah I know I cannot easily take things
have changed wow what a stupid play
[Music]
d5 looks incredibly try to be crazy
young but if i take take take 97
[Music]
Oh
amazing how you can spoil a good
position to this crap yeah it beckoned
in a split second amazing ready I mean
it was good i'm not i'm not saying that
I was better or anything but you
definitely shouldn't be in a situation
like that I mean that's really
unacceptable remarkable okay
[Music]
hmm I don't believe this is particularly
great to put the bishop dammit maybe he
can afford even that time morning and I
think things could have been worse even
but they're still bad maybe rookie six
wins straightaway takes takes I'm not
sure how I'm stopping the pawn
I don't see anything m98 as weird as it
looks
don't write off or what didn't see any
other move now he's just just taking a
pawn right
yeah it's absolutely impossible to do
anything else a problem you just have a
position where you cannot know anything
check
I thought you never create them check
mmm it's the thing not even that
Luke check on default actually would be
made but it feels unlikely that this is
materializing
g6 ruki I'd made a funny check that is
black for it's unlikely i'll see you and
take now but okay I'm losing on time
yeah that was bad I mean here should
never be rude but I can completely
completely bungled this up so let's have
a look there yeah just did not did not
register that night at five now is a
threat bit early success engine / edit
that so that move I dislike I mean I
wanted to do more here candid what about
this now probably did success to weaken
now maybe I shouldn't have played c6 I
mean that move is not necessary it was
just the most ambitious because I wanted
to do something in this position not
just sit around when to prevent 97 maybe
I should do that this kind of thing yeah
it's probably gone when I wanted to play
for an advantage of course and just
totally ignored this idea yeah d5 I saw
the move but I felt like that that
cannot work somehow the computer wants
to do it yeah I felt that that shouldn't
work I mean I thought he just goes back
but then f6 oh god no I didn't see f6
hmm and maybe this is still playable
check check yeah this is this is not I
mean this is not pieces are incredibly
badly positioned so I am 95
at this immediately I hit this rookie 6
move which irritated me on IG H actually
I'm actually okay again great great oh
man what a bad game and I felt like he
played it bad technically it was pretty
clear that it wasn't the best way but I
didn't exploit anything just take it
arab td6 is good though and now i'm i'm
in this in this in this bad bad
situation x don't move anything check
position is amazingly amazing Shack bad
check can only hope for a for a miracle
I like some I don't know what exactly
Haruki idea yeah okay it's just losing
poor that wasn't good thanks for
watching